neue hinweise auf leben auf dem mars
sind gleich mehrere spannende
entdeckungen auf dem mars die
forschungsteams weltweit jetzt in
aufregung versetzen
alle drehen sich um die spannende frage
nach wasser dort und der existenz von
leben können uns die neuen erkenntnisse
möglicherweise sogar zu den orten führen
wo sich lebewesen auf dem roten planeten
versteckt halten
klicks und saß im flugzeug gibt es
dreimal pro woche spannendes heinz
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's herzlich willkommen am
schluss dieses videos habe ich noch
exklusiv eine ziemlich coole sohn
konferenz für euch bei der ihr dabei
sein könnt und hierauf klicks um
exklusiv unter anderem mit esa
generaldirektor josef aschbacher und der
astronaut den kandidaten in satigny
zusammentrifft anmelden könnt ihr euch
hier und ami der link ist natürlich auch
in der video beschreibung und im
angehefteten kommentar das ist
unumstritten das vorhandensein von
wasser ist eine wichtige voraussetzung
dafür dass sich leben entwickeln kann
und so wird auch bei der erforschung des
mars intensiv nach wasser gesucht wasser
selbst konnte auf dem roten planeten
bereits durch einige raumsonden und auch
durch mars rover bereits nachgewiesen
werden ungeklärt dagegen die frage die
eng mit der wasser frage verknüpft ist
existierte in der vergangenheit einmal
leben auf dem mars oder hält es sich
sogar bis heute auf diesem planeten
versteckt fachleute weltweit zweifeln
mittlerweile nicht mehr daran dass es
auf dem mars einst sogar große mengen
flüssigen wassers gegeben haben muss vor
allem der amerikanischen weltraumbehörde
nasa sind in den vergangenen jahren
einige spannende funde gelungen die
genau darauf hinweisen demnach gab es
sogar mal eine zeit in der wasser auf
dem mars in großflächigen sehen
schwappte und durchflüsse floss davon
sollten einige ausgetrocknete
flussbetten und teller auf dem roten
planeten die forschende aufspüren
konnten und so ist die fachwelt sich
zudem auch sicher dass es vor allem an
den polen des roten planeten auch heute
noch wasser gibt dass dort in
unterirdischen eiskappen eingeschlossen
ist also flüssiges wasser eine der
bislang großen ungelösten fragen der
wissenschaft lautet wie hat der mars im
laufe der zeit sein wasser verloren und
inwieweit hat sich dadurch die
bewohnbarkeit des planeten verändert
genau dazu hat jetzt ein nasa
forschungsteam spannende erkenntnisse
zusammengetragen dazu der nasa-forscher
giuliano uci vom nasa goddard space
center die messungen bestätigen dass der
planet über die zeit große wassermengen
verloren hat die aktuelle studie zeigt
nämlich dass der mars im wahrsten sinne
des wortes schwitzt das forschungsteam
hat in der atmosphäre des roten planeten
wasserstoff und sauerstoff entdeckt die
aus dieser austreten dazu hatten die
fachleute die atmosphäre mit hilfe von
nomad genauer ins visier genommen dabei
handelt es sich um ein messinstrument
dass sich an bord des masters exomars
trace gas orbiter tgo befindet und zur
europäischen raumfahrtorganisation esa
und der russischen weltraumorganisation
roskosmos gehört dazu schreibt das
forschungsteam dieses fantastische
instrument gibt uns eine nie dagewesene
sicht auf wasser isotope in der mars
atmosphäre
konkret haben den vorständen also spuren
von wasserstoff entdeckt und zwar bei
ihrer analyse des lichts das durch die
dünne mars atmosphäre tritt diese
erkenntnisse geben dem forschungsteam
zufolge entscheidende hinweise darauf
zitat wie der mast im laufe der zeit
sein wasser verloren hat und
entsprechend wie die bewohnbarkeit des
mars sich im laufe der geschichte
verändert hat
die aktuelle analyse offenbart im
beobachtungszeitraum von april 2008 bis
april 2009 10 3 fälle durch den der
wasserverlust aus der mars atmosphäre
zugenommen hat zum einen der globale
staubsturm auf dem mars im jahr 2008
sind dann ein kurzer und intensiver
regionaler sturm im januar 2009 10 sowie
verdunsten das wasser von der eiskappe
am südpol in den sommermonaten vor allem
in heißen sommern verliert der mars
demnach große mengen an wasser dazu
schreibt das forschungsteam die
jahreszeiten auf dem mars und besonders
der relativ heiße sommer auf der
südhalbkugel scheinen die treibenden
kräfte hinter unseren neuen
beobachtungen zu sein
die beobachtungen des trays ob etwas
ermöglichen uns ein ganz neues ausmaß
der erforschung der mars atmosphäre auch
andere fachleute stufen diese
erkenntnisse als folgenreich 1
so beispielsweise auch die
wissenschafterin zu horn von der
britischen raumfahrtbehörde
ihrer meinung nach sei der nachweis von
wasser in der marsatmosphäre ein zitat
schlüsselelement bei unserem aktuellen
versuch die mysterien des roten planeten
zu durchdringen
die aktuellen studienergebnisse könnten
ihrer meinung nach entscheidend dazu
beitragen
endlich die frage zu beantworten ob es
einmal leben auf dem mars gab
in der zukunft sollen koordinierte
beobachtung mit weiteren raum fahrzeugen
ein detailliertes bild dazu abgeben
beispielsweise könnte die nasa-raumsonde
menschen dabei helfen die obere
atmosphäre des mars zu analysieren zu
einer weiteren spannenden erkenntnisse
in sachen mars atmosphäre und der frage
nach leben auf diesem planeten kam ein
forschungsteam aus hongkong demnach
hatte der mars in seiner vergangenheit
wohl einmal eine so genannte
reduzierende atmosphäre kurze erklärung
sowohl die erde als auch der rote planet
haben derzeit eine sogenannte oxidieren
der atmosphäre
diesen begriff kennt man noch aus dem
chemieunterricht ist bedeutet so viel
wie sauerstoff aufnehmen das erklärt
warum materialien aus eisen sowohl auf
der erde als auch auf dem mars rosten
doch wirft man einen blick in die
vergangenheit der erde wird klar dass
sich diese oxidieren der erdatmosphäre
erst entwickelt hat zuvor besaß die erde
also eine reduzierende atmosphäre heißt
vor drei milliarden jahren hätten wir
menschen auf der erde keine
überlebenschance gehabt denn die
erdatmosphäre entschieden damals weniger
als ein promille sauerstoff und das ist
für lebewesen die sauerstoff atmen
einfach zu wenig dann kam es zum so
genannten race oxidation events von rund
2,4 milliarden jahren dabei stieg der
sauerstoffgehalt der atmosphäre relativ
schnell bis auf rund 20 prozent an somit
konnten sich dann die ersten tiere
entwickeln dieser prozess geschah nach
meinung vieler fachleute unter anderem
auch durch die hilfe von lebewesen die
photosynthese betreiben beispielsweise
durch cyanobakterien die also begannen
sauerstoff frei zu setzen
die aktuelle studie wirft jetzt die
frage in den raum wie genau der
sauerstoff in die atmosphäre des mars
gelang waren hier etwa auch lebewesen
beteiligt das forschungsteam aus
hongkong schreibt nun jedenfalls in der
aktuellen studie dass es wohl auch auf
dem roten planeten ein großes
sauerstoffanreicherung ereignis gegeben
haben muss für ihre analyse hatten die
forschenden unter anderem die geo chemie
und mineralogie urzeitlicher gesteine
auf dem mars mit hilfe von infrarot
messgeräten genauer ins visier genommen
diese ergebnisse verglichen die
fachleute dann mit ihren ergebnissen zu
den verwitterten vulkangestein von der
insel hainan im südwesten chinas der
vergleich offenbart gesteine die an der
auf flächen des mars verwittert waren
taten dies der aktuellen analyse zufolge
wohl unter reduzierten atmosphären
bedingungen zu vernachlässigen seien
dabei natürlich nicht möglich lokale
unterschiede zwischen mars und erde so
die fachleute dennoch schreiben sie in
ihrer studie
da sauerstoff ein abfallprodukt von
stoffwechselprozessen wie der
photosynthese ist hätte dieser sich ohne
mikroben die sauerstoff produzieren
nicht in unsere atmosphäre ansammeln
können und wir wären nicht hier
hier stellt sich nach meinung des
forschungsteams die frage was diese
neuen erkenntnisse für eine potentielle
frühjahrs biosphäre bedeuten könnten
außer acht gelassen werden darf an
dieser stelle allerdings nicht dass auch
nicht biologische prozesse zu einem
übergang von einer reduzierenden zu
einer oxidieren atmosphäre führen können
dennoch ist nicht abzustreiten dass
gerade genannte biologische weit oben
auf der liste der bislang bekannten
prozesse steht zudem zeigen auch
messungen des mars rover curiosity dass
der sauerstoffgehalt in der gashülle des
mars überraschend stark schwankt demnach
steigen die werte im frühjahr um 30 und
das ist weit mehr als das gängige
prozesse erklären können woher dieser
sauerstoff kommt und wohin er im herbst
wieder verschwindet ist daher noch
völlig rätselhaft dann wirklich
mysteriöses phänomen führt dass die
fachwelt bislang noch keine erklärung
hat dass dieses phänomen etwas mit der
atmosphären dynamik zu tun hat das ist
wohl eher unwahrscheinlich denn die
werte wiederholen sich ja nicht exakt
sondern schwanken jedes jahr dazu die
nasa mitarbeiterin lisa trainer im
moment tun wir uns schwer damit eine
erklärung zu finden möglicherweise
steckt eine chemische quelle und senke
dahinter die bislang noch nicht bekannt
ist doch die fachleute wissen dass
sowohl methan der ja auch schwankend in
der marsatmosphäre vorkommt als auch
sauerstoff theoretisch durch biologische
oder chemische prozesse auf dem mars
erzeugt werden könnten
das große problem curiosity kann dies
nicht analysieren und somit bleibt
weiter offen welchen ursprung der
sauerstoff hat kommen wir damit zur
dritten großen erkenntnis die einem us
forschungsteam nun bezüglich der wasser
frage auf dem mars gelungen ist zudem
könnte uns diese entdeckung
möglicherweise sogar porte aufzeigen an
denen heute noch leben auf dem mars
existiert konkret konnten die fachleute
staubiges wassereis bis in die niedrigen
breitengrade dessen
das aufspüren das spannende an diesen
ice lagern
diese könnten sich nahe genug am äquator
befinden so dass das eis im sommer
schmelzen könnte das schmelzen dieses
lager könnte damit also nicht nur für
die bereits aufgespürten abschluss
struktur verantwortlich sein sondern uns
sogar orte zeigen an denen sich noch
heute leben auf dem mars befindet
denn genau dort könnten in den
sommermonaten möglicherweise immer
wieder kleine mengen an flüssigem wasser
entstehen dazu schreibt das
forschungsteam
wir glauben dass dieses lagert die
besten kandidaten für jene orte sind und
nach kleinen mengen flüssigen wassers in
den sommermonaten und damit auch nach
opfern zu suchen wo es heute noch leben
auf dem mars geben könnte
und auch für zukünftige maß visionen
könnten dieses lager von besonderem
interesse sein
denn maß astronautinnen und mars
astronauten könnten diese viel besser
erreichen
diese liegen nach ansicht der fachleute
zitat so nah an der oberfläche dass sie
vielleicht sogar schon mit schaufeln
geborgen werden könnten und exklusiv
hier auf klicks und könnt ihr
zusammentreffen mit esa generaldirektor
josef aschbacher der astronautin
kandidaten in sat 1 dem
europaabgeordneten niklas ninas von den
grünen und mir unser thema das space
race 2.0 und die europa nicht den
anschluss verliert anmelden könnt ihr
euch hier also anklicken und dann dabei
sein und das ganze gibt es dann live
auch hier auf tricks um am 18 märz um 19
uhr ich freue mich auf euch und eine
rege teilnahme der link ist natürlich
auch in der video beschreibung und im
angebundenen kommentar bis dann bleibt
dran